um and you know even places like the nba
we we announced a partnership with you
all the mbas have
have aura rings i saw that in the bubble
yeah wnba
what was that able to do for them they
just knew people's temperatures
no well i mean look i think with all
these tests even even if people are
getting tested every day like they were
in both the nba wnba and some of these
other sports leagues right um
you know there's false positives there's
false negatives and again you could see
from this data if you're getting sick
even before you feel symptoms
so i think it gave people a sense of
security you know if there's false
positives false negatives you have
another set of data to look at
which is super helpful and and and
frankly like most organizations can't
afford to test every day you couldn't
even get tests in the beginning right
i mean that was i think for me one of
the biggest tragedies is i had friends
who were getting tests from
taiwan hong kong yeah finland other
countries and
had at home testing kits that cost 20
bucks each that were
probably marked up triple because they
were being brought in here
and our fda for some reason the fda in
the united states or whatever
forces did not allow mass testing at
home to occur
because it wasn't perfect and it's like
it doesn't need to be perfect it needs
to be directionally correct so that if
you do have a positive
you go get the more perfect test yeah
it's just
ridiculous and look i think i think it's
a hard it is a hard science right
flues adapt we're seeing variations
right now i think even the latest indian
you know version that's going through
there some of the mutations there looks
like you know not
the vaccines aren't having as high
effectiveness as they would with some
other strains
and that's how these these flus evolve
right they keep evolving and so
i i you know for us is as frustrating
obviously as it is we just thought about
how can we help
and so i think being able to be you know
forward there working with you know
honestly frontline healthcare workers
was the first group the temper deck
study we
you know actually donated 2 000 rings
and had a sponsor come in to donate
another thousand rings to full-time
healthcare workers
um you know that are out there in the
hospitals across the u.s to be able to
do the study to then
deploy a product and and serve different
organizations but you know i
so we talked to the nba gets a lot of
publicity but what did it was las vegas
sands
so we we we announced you know casino
workers going back to work
right um you know they don't want to be
laid off you know so the sans group was
like hey we got to help reopen vegas
you know because otherwise we're going
to have zero fascinating and low and lay
people off and so
you know but they couldn't afford to
test every day right every single person
and so you know using our data they're
able to prioritize testing to the right
folks
um or if someone looked like they're
getting sick hey maybe you shouldn't
come in today
um we actually made it so you could
customize a notification as an admin
and you just saw aggregate data so you
know we got through all the privacy
stuff created some really cool
frameworks
uh to do that and so now you know we're
seeing interest from a lot of
corporations as they go back to the
office
there's gonna be variants you know every
flu season frankly